henry cavill fans aren't the only ones
who are thirsty the new face of Geralt
of Rivia recently sat down with Graham
Norton back in his native England to
talk about his role on Netflix as The
Witcher the scene everyone was desperate
for after the first Witcher trailer
arrived the monster hunting Geralt
sitting in that famous wooden bathtub
naked as the day he was born
was the big clip featured during cattles
interview with Norton and that naturally
invited questions about how he prepared
for the witcher's most famous scene
bands are at least casually familiar in
this age of Thor's and Superman that the
diet required to maintain a perfectly
sculpted Brickhouse physique is
punishing and mostly comprised of eating
ones weight and phoneless skinless
chicken breasts chatting with Norton
about how he got ready to portray Geralt
cavil revealed a new twist in the horror
show that putting perfect bodies on film
necessitates purposefully dehydrating
himself over several days cavil
explained that the worst part about
playing Geralt was the sharp decline in
fluid intake he had to endure to get
ready for all the shirtless scenes he
told Norton on the first day you'll have
like a liter and a half of water the
second day 1/2 litre and then the third
day no water and you'll shoot on the 4th
he went on to say that by the time he's
done shooting on that 4th day he's quote
the most miserable person on earth but
why doe isn't putting cavil through an
incredibly bland and utilitarian diet
for months on end for the sake of vanity
enough makes your skin really thin so it
sits on the muscles this method of
purposeful dehydration is a common one
for bodybuilders preparing for
competition or photoshoots boxers and
MMA fighters trying to drop pounds
before weigh-ins and actors alike
Kirk cavil is still massive in size and
could probably crush a watermelon
between his bicep and forearm but the
high definition cut of his musculature
requires tricking the body temporarily
warning we don't recommend trying any of
this without medical supervision
dehydrating is the final step in the
process towards a temporary period of
maximum muscle definition and
bodybuilders refer to it as peak day
the first stage about two weeks before
the target date requires temporarily
increasing your sodium consumption which
tricks the body's usual water retention
ratio at first it will retain water but
eventually readapt and normalize when
sodium intake is severely cut a week
later water will rapidly exit the body
along with it
many
there's almost no added water weight or
possible bloating because of it along
with this process consumption of carbs
are cut to almost nothing this
temporarily supercharges burning the
miniscule amount of excess fat left in
the body it's a precarious balancing act
to increasingly deprive yourself of
water and yet give your muscles enough
hydration to handle those workouts that
still have to get done the skin thins
for the lack of fluid within and
underneath it giving that last little
bit of definition at the end of all that
you get exactly one perfect day to get
slicked over with baby oil and tossed in
to tastefully opaque bath water for 5
minutes of sexy footage for The Witcher
Cavill had to go through this grueling
process repeatedly for every single one
of the several scenes in which he's
featured shirtless because a supercut
physique can't be consistently
maintained for the weeks and weeks it
takes to film a TV series you're hungry
and thirsty and when you're not working
in front of a camera you're still
working off-site in a gym with an entire
team of people monitoring you down to
the finest dehumanizing detail Cavill
said in the interview that by the end of
all those day poor shoots he had a
peculiar sensation you get to the point
on the lost day where you can smell
water like nearby sounds like one of
Gerald's special skills I smelled what
you were doing
Plus Henry Cavill for his dedication and
patience because this whole process
sounds like the absolute worst see the
results for yourself on Netflix where a
season 1 of The Witcher is now streaming
in its entirety check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you